the descendants to cast has always stuck
between good and evil but when people
began to suddenly disappear mal and uma
band together to solve this mystery stay
tuned until the end to find out if mal
will ever get to see King Ben again our
story involves a missing key missing
boys and a golden compass that will
guide the way mal has returned to the
Isle of the Lost
she's trapped under the watchful eye of
her mother Maleficent Ouma who now runs
the isle shows up at Mouse one evening
in dire need of help now
I need your help come on I need you now
I can't Maleficent will get mad if she
finds out that I left when have you ever
cared about that since she took Ben
hostage to try and control me what she
took Ben yeah she wants to stop Ben from
running auradon why I don't know I think
she's trying to take over the Isle of
the Lost as well this is why I need you
mouth you're the Isles only hope what's
going on we need to find the compass
that will point us in the direction of
people who've gone missing people who've
gone missing seems like I have some
people disappearing on my end too what
who
Harry Hook and Carlos deville they're
gone and I need them to run the isle
Lumis stares at mal desperation in her
eyes mal looks around considering what
uma said okay let's go
where do we start I think that Jafar has
the compass hidden somewhere this
compass will point to where Harry and
Carlos have been taken it's a magical
compass that we made when we took over
the Isle just in case something like
this ever happened but around the time
that the boys's appeared I caught Jafar
sneaked around our ship you think that
he took them I think something bigger is
going on here
I think Jafar and maybe even Maleficent
are trying to take back the Isle of the
Lost from us I think you're right Ouma
something's definitely going on but this
was only half true Maleficent had
started an evil task of capturing the
children one by one was Jafar involved
in this evil plan
Maleficent already has been and Jafar
might have Harry and Karla
it won't be long until more kids begin
to disappear we need to save them now so
that we can put an end to this let's go
get that compass uma and maou head out
of the castle and over to Jafar's home
but as they get closer they see that
Jafar is tied up they rush over to him
and untie him oh boy
this isn't good what's going on Jafar
Maleficent threw this place apart in
search of the compass wait you guys
aren't working together no I hid the
boys to protect them from her you'll
need to take this compass if you want to
find them Jafar lifts a floorboard and
retrieves the golden compass he gives it
to the girls so that they can find Harry
and Carlos before Maleficent gets to
them Thank You Jafar the two girls start
to leave but Jafar stops them wait she
left this behind when she broke in Jafar
holds up a golden key oh my gosh
this must be the key that will free Ben
go go now save them all I'll go get the
boys and you go free Ben the girls run
off in separate directions as
mountaineers the castle she sees the
lights flicker inside this means that
Maleficent is home mouse sneaks down
into the dungeon to save them Oh mal you
came back for me Shh and don't act too
surprised I wouldn't just let you rot
here or would i hey enough joking around
get me out of here mal turns the key in
the lock in the dungeon door swings open
then in Mallen brace but there moment is
interrupted by a loud sound coming from
upstairs she's coming come on let's go
they both look up Malon been rushed
through the back corridor and run out of
the castle you're always saving me mal
one day you'll have to get caught so
that I can save you he'll never get
caught at that exact moment the light
flickers on in another room of the
castle as to the whets of Maleficent
appears in the front window Ben go save
auradon I'm gonna go help Ouma until
next time until next time cutie then in
mal hurry off in opposite directions
King Ben to roll auradon and mal to help
Ouma find at the missing boys they
barely avoided getting caught by
Maleficent
or the Maleficent see them next time
they won't be so lucky that's it for our
descendants to fanfiction story told in
emojis which characters would you like
in our next fanfiction video let us know
in the comments below thanks for
watching
[Music]